auf den ersten blick jedenfalls wenn man
einfach von bord kommt wort gottes
theologie dialektische theologie und so
weiter scheint es erstmal so zu sein als
ob nichts mit den ganz großen denkern
der klassischen deutschen philosophie zu
tun hätte wenn man jetzt an hegel und
kant denkt er scheint es so als ob barth
mit denkern wie sören kierkegaard zu tun
hat das ist natürlich auch bekannter wie
bei kirche gott ist es bei bad so dass
er in einer kritischen distanz durchaus
steht zu auffassung einer autonomen
vernunft die aus sich heraus alles setzt
es ist auch bekannt dass bad seinerzeit
eben gegen den theologischen
rationalismus der aufklärung und die
liberale theologie derzeit seinerzeit
auch durchaus kritisch gegenüber
eingestellt war so dass er durch
mitunter als neo orthodox eingestuft
werden konnte also wie kann es dann sein
dass ich bald mit kants vernunft begriff
und hegels geist begriff intensiv
befasst hat wie ich heute versuche zu
zeigen wo er eben doch im zuge seiner
wort gottes theologie denker wie luther
und kirchenchor die nicht etwa die
grenzen sollen die gänzliche impotenz
der menschlichen rationalität man denke
etwa an luthers rede von der [ __ ]
vernunft besonders herauszustellen
versuchten dort ist wie ich im folgenden
zeigen versuche durchaus auch ein
vernunft kritiker im gefolge von kant
jedoch vernunft kritiker in einem
anderen sinne vernunft kritiker insofern
als er sich wie auch der titel eines
vortrags sagt mit den grenzen der
vernunft besonders befasst aber wie es
mit allen untersuchungen über die
grenzen der fall ist wenn man über die
grenze bringt ist man halt schon über
die grenze hinaus und um diese dialektik
von grenzziehung und grenzübergängen
soll es jetzt in meinem vortrag gehen
wie ich schon sagte gegenüber dem
vorwurf einer unkritischen orthodoxie
agha eines irrationalismus steht die
tatsache dass ich bald verstreut in
seinem werk vor allem aber in seiner
schrift über die protestantische
theologie im neunzehnten jahrhundert
explizit mit kann und anderen
philosophen des deutschen idealismus
allen voran hegel auseinandergesetzt hat
wie passt kann man noch mal fragen diese
intensive auseinandersetzung mit kant
und dem deutschen idealismus der doch
alles andere als orthodox seien vielmehr
kritisch ist und die vernunft ins
zentrum stellt zur theologie ohne frage
ist hier goss philosophie verbot von
großer bedeutung
doch darf dahinter nicht die zentrale
stellung der klassischen deutschen
philosophie insbesondere diejenige ganz
verdeckt werden
dass dies für das diese philosophie
kants verbat prägend war wird bereits
aus seinem biografischen umständen
deutlich wie sie alle wissen hat bat in
marburg studiert und war daher besonders
durch neu kampanische philosophen wie
hermann cohen und paul natorp aber auch
durch den ebenso stark von kant
geprägten theologen wilhelm hermann
beeinflusst auch balz bruder heinrich
barth hatte in marburg bei hermann cohen
und paul otto studiert die beiden
denkern kant und hegel aber auch
schleiermacher interessanterweise
ausdrücklich nicht aber fichte und
schelling gelten verbat als typen die
besondere züge ihres jeweiligen
zeitalters exemplarisch manifestieren
beschreibt zitat an fichte und schelling
kann man vorbeikommen an hegel so wenig
wie an kant also bat rezeption der
klassischen deutschen philosophie ist
durchaus selektiv gewichtet nicht alle
denker gleichermaßen man könnte jetzt
auf den ersten blick denken
schelling spielte eine besondere rolle
aber jedenfalls in der philosophie in
der theologie der geschichte theologie
des 19 jahrhunderts kommt überhaupt kein
eigener antrag vor der schelling
gewidmet ist und auch nicht sondern es
kommt herr da dran
zbs kommt normales ist ein kapitel drin
aber interessanter weil es eben nicht zu
fürchten und zur stelle und das ist
durchaus mal auffällig weil man könnte
doch jetzt sagen gut schelling vor allem
der späte schelling ist näher an seine
existenz philosophie dran wie auch
kirche gordon herbert wichtig wurde aber
er behandelt schelling nicht
ausdrücklich so wie er es bei kant und
hegel kant und hegel werden verbaut wie
ich schon sagte zu typen oder
repräsentanten wie auch alle anderen
philosophen und denkt an diesem buch in
seiner geschichte der theologie des 19
jahrhunderts und bad sagt dass kant der
vollende der mensch des achtzehnten
jahrhunderts war während schleiermacher
dem er auch dann ein kapitel widmet ein
zitat ganz und gar moderner mensch
gewesen sein
ganz philosophisch charakterisiert
allgemein als die zitat tiefste
philosophie des 19 jahrhunderts hegels
philosoph hingegen als die zitat
radikalste also ist es so dass bad sich
diesen denkern kant hegel und schelling
jetzt nicht so sehr in jedem detail
widmet sondern sie eher als
exemplarische figuren
geistesgeschichtliche figuren auf fast
an denen sich gewissermaßen züge er
hinsichtlich des verhältnisses von
philosophie und theologie besonders
kristallisieren besonders manifestieren
und durch deren analyse bat dann wie ich
zu zeigen versuche auch die weitere
geologische entwicklung in der folge des
19 jahrhunderts zu kritisieren und auch
in gewissen in gewisser weise wege
aufzuzeigen wie sich diese entwicklung
anders hätte gestalten können
das ist so das hätte bald verhandelt die
philosophen des deutschen idealismus vor
allem kant und hegel wie ich schon sagte
im rahmen einer geschichte der neueren
protestantischen theologie und diese
geschichte trägt den untertitel ihre
geschichte ihre vorgeschichte und ihre
geschichte interessant ist dass er das
bad die denker der klassischen deutschen
also vor allem jetzt eben kann und in
jedem teil behandelt den er mit
vorgeschichte betitelt darin behandelt
baut unter anderem russo lessing herder
novalis eben auch kant und hegel
er ist ihnen darauf folgenden zweiten
teil der mit geschichte verschrieben ist
combat dann auf schleiermacher zu
sprechen und behandelt dann in folgen
unter anderem feuerbach strauß und endet
bei albrecht ritschl die behandlung der
denker des deutschen idealismus versteht
bad also als vorgeschichte der theologie
des 19 jahrhunderts dir wiederum von der
geschichte des 18 jahrhunderts abgrenzt
an dieser positionierung wird klar dass
ich bald dem deutschen idealismus des
deutschen tennis muss deswegen bedient
um die folgen der theologische
entwicklung kritisch prüfen zu können
das bad ist sich dabei durchaus bewusst
dass man nicht mehr hinter kant
unkritisch zurückfallen kann
generell legt er deswegen wert darauf zu
zeigen dass ich vernunft religion
philosophie und theologie im deutschen
tourismus nicht ausschließen weil die
aufgeklärte haltung zur vernunft immer
eine besondere ist bad hebt insbesondere
bei seiner analyse kann sich noch zeigen
werde den primat der praktischen vor der
theoretischen vernunft hervor
auch wenn er immer wieder darauf bezug
nimmt das kann ein kritischer denker ist
und ganz klar ihre grenzen dem denken
und auch der theologie gezogen hat barth
entwickelt so könnte man sagen in
auseinandersetzung mit kant und auch
higl eine immanente kritik der
jeweiligen positionen die es jemandem
ende erlaubt verschiedene neuere
entwicklungen der theologie seinerzeit
zu kritisieren damit kann bat gegenüber
dem vorwurf in schutz genommen werden
wonach er der vernunft nur wenig
beachtung schenkt oder sie gar ignoriert
vielmehr sind es gerade die grenzen der
vernunft die ihn besonders interessieren
und die er durchaus kritisch entlang von
kant und hegel analysiert ich werde
jetzt im folgenden einige zentrale
zitate aus diesem reichen fundus an
diese geschichte der theologie des 19
jahrhunderts auswählen und präsentieren
und versuchen zu analysieren mit blick
auf die rolle der grenze die darin
vorkommt ich komme jetzt zum ersten
punkt bad und kant dass die philosophie
immanuel kants für karl barth bereits
früh eine rolle gespielt hat zeigen
seine autobiographischen bemerkungen war
zac nämlich in schreibt rückblickend
das erste buch das mich als student
ergänze wohl in marburg wirklich bewegt
hat war kants kritik der praktischen
vernunft wieder interessantes sie nicht
die kritik der reinen vernunft die ja in
der regel erst am anfang steht dieser
teil kritiken man geht denke ich
sicherlich auch im studium häufig durch
das man mit der ersten kritik beginnt
und dann die zweite und dann die
kritiker an dritte kritik an schließt
aber es ist so dass für ihn besonders
die kritik der praktischen vernunft
im zentrum steht diese kritik der
praktischen vernunft erweist sich
deswegen als zentral verbat weil es hier
gewissermaßen um eine doppelte
grenzziehung geht zunächst einmal um das
theoretische wissen dann aber eben auch
und das praktische wissen diese zwei
formen des wissens sind nicht zwei
geteilt oder existieren unabhängig
voneinander sondern das hat denke ich
auch party zu ihrem sinn gehabt das
praktische wissen für das theoretische
ford ersetzt dort an wo das theoretische
wissen seine absolute grenze findet und
in dem platz immer wieder diese positive
konstruktive leistung der kritik der
praktischen vernunft vor allem auch des
vermögens der praktischen vernunft
betont wendet er sich auch gegen die
durchaus auch in der theologie
seinerzeit weit verbreitete ansicht das
kann ein bloßer zertrümmerer der
philosophie gewesen zahlen barth sagte
ich zitiere dieses unternehmen von kant
also diese kritik der vernunft hat aber
eine andere seite eine positive seite
auch und gerade die erkenntnis aus
reiner von uns
ist nach kant wirkliche vernunft
erkenntnis so gewiss sie auch alle
erfahrungs erkenntnis notwendig ist die
vernunft muss ich aber als reine
vernunft verstehen lernen
sie hat sich selber noch nicht
verstanden so lange sie sich bloß als
theoretische vernunft solange sie sich
nicht als handelnde als praktische
vernunft verstanden hat die praktische
vernunft so fährt fort in der lehre kann
es ist nicht eine art zweiter vernunft
neben der theoretischen sondern die eine
vernunft die auch theoretische ist ist
auch und muss gerade zu sagen sie ist
primär praktische vernunft handlung
praxis ist ja auch die in der
transzendentalen perzeption begründete
einheit von anschauen begriff in welcher
die erfahrung des erkenntnis wirklich
ist hier sieht man durchaus das bad
existenz orientierte denkweise die sich
in der die rinde einer dialektischen
theologie aber auch in dem wort gottes
theologie immer findet der bezug auf die
existenz des individuums durchaus mit
kants kritik der vernunft in eine
beziehung setzen lässt also ist es nicht
so dass kant jetzt hier nur der vernunft
denker ist sondern in dem kant nach bad
der von grenzen setzt und bestimmte
ausprägung der vernunft gegenüber
anderen ausprägung oder vermögen in ein
verhältnis setzt in ein verhältnis der
über ordnung kann bad zeigen dass sich
hierbei kann ähnliche tendenzen finden
lassen die auch für seine eigene
theologie prägen sind dort führt fort
und fährt fort und hier wird wieder
entscheiden das bad auch bei kant den
wirklichen menschen ins zentrum stellt
nicht nur den theoretischen er sagt
folgendes mit bezug auf kante abstrakt
als theoretisch vernünftige vernünftiges
wesen verstandene mensch ist nicht der
wirkliche mensch wirklicher mensch
wirkliches vernunft wesen bin ich nicht
schon kraft jenes vermögens dinge im
raum und in der zeit zu erkennen sondern
dieses vermögen
im raum und in der zeit erkennen ist
selber begründet in dem eigentlichen und
entscheidenden von unvermögen kraft
dessen ich notwendigkeit gesetz erkennen
nämlich so dass ich mir selber als
handelnde person notwendigkeit und das
mir selbst als handelnde person
notwendigkeit und gesetz aufgelegt wird
in der praktischen philosophie tritt bei
kant sobald der wirkliche mensch ins
zentrum und dadurch lässt sich eben auch
ganz kritischer philosophie ein verbot
auch in theologischer hinsicht positiver
aspekt abgewinnen
von besonderer bedeutung erweist sich
jedoch verbat kann's kritische
philosophie in sofern sie eine
philosophie die kritik und grenze ist
die dialektik von grenze und
grenzüberschreitung des gedenkens und
über denkens von grenzen zieht sich
dabei wie ein roter faden durch das werk
und auch vor allem eben durch diese
geschichte der theologie des neunzehnten
jahrhunderts jetzt will ich aber mit
gehen mit einem zitat aus einem anderen
werk das aber gleichwohl sich mit ganz
begriff oder these der grenze befasst
nämlich mit der zweiten fassung seines
römerbrief 22 dort findet sich in der
auslegung von römer 8 vers 1 und 2 eine
ein bezug zu kant und interessanterweise
auch auf seine sein verständnis der
grenze ist jemals das zitat 1 auf dem
textblatt zitat dass der mensch der
mensch ist dieses seltsam demütigende
kann er sich offenbar nicht selbst sagen
sondern das muss ihnen gesagt sein
geantwortet seien vorher gerufen hat der
ort von dem aus der ganze geschlossene
kreis als solcher zu sehen ist kann
selber nicht innerhalb des kreises
liegen die möglichkeit des menschen
möglich als solches in seiner
beschränkung zu erfassen ist offenbar
und wenn wir uns von kant jeden blick
über das beschränkende hinaus verbieten
ließen ja gerade dann eine ganz unerhört
neue möglichkeit also hier anders als
dann wie ich zeigen werde
der geschichte theologie des 19
jahrhunderts dient kant als derjenige
der grenzen setzt hier jetzt aber noch
mehr als jemand der sogar den blick über
diese grenze eigentlich nicht zulässt
das ist die perspektive aus dieser
römerbrief auslegung aber auch hier eben
das ist mir wichtig zu betont die in
kant als jemand der einfach grenzen
setzt dieses kritische moment bei stört
besonders intensiv setzt sich bart
jedoch mit kant in seiner
protestantischen theologie im 19
jahrhundert auseinander die direkt nach
dem ende des zweiten weltkriegs 1946 47
der ersten ausleihe auflage erschien
jedoch bereits im jahr 1933 aus einer
bonner vorlesung hervorgegangen waren
und die dann wie bad im vorwort schreibt
als 1000 zurückbleiben mussten als die
nationalsozialisten an die macht kam
rabat interessiert sich insbesondere
darin für tanz projekt eine aufklärung
der vernunft und interessant ist wie ich
schon sagte das bad ähnlich wie in
dieser römerbrief auslegung mit der
kritischen grenze bekannt in verbindung
bringt nun aber anders als im ersten
zitat vielmehr scheint diese kritische
grenze durchaus positiv bewertet das ist
jetzt das zitat das ist ein generelle
einschätzung von kant wir sie bei allen
diesen denkern in der vorgeschichte
vornimmt zitat 2 in diesem mann nämlich
erkannt und in diesem werk hat das
achtzehnte jahrhundert sich selber in
seinen grenzen gesehen verstanden und
bejaht sich selber in seinen grenzen
damit sagen wir das virus so und lessing
so auch kant an der wende der zeiten
steht wir müssen aber sofort hinzu fügen
eben in dem bei kant nur dieses ganz
schlichte stattfindet keine öffnung
einer neuen diskussion keine entdeckung
neuer provinzen kräfte wie barroso und
lessing
es darauf an so könnte es uns wohl
geschehen dass uns kant nach russ sohn
lasse wie ein reaktionär vorkommen
möchte nur dies schlicht eine
verständigung dieses jahrhunderts über
sich selber aber über sich selber in
seinen grenzen in dem bei kant nur eben
dieses stattfindet steht er faktisch
viel prinzipieller viel umfassender und
radikaler und geschichtlich gesprochen
viel interessanter und bedeutungsvoller
an lina wände der zeiten also ganz
allgemein zeigt sich nach bad in der
person kann es in den geschichtlichen
stellung kann es schon dieses
entscheidenden moment der grenze und der
grenzziehung nun aber wendet bat diese
kritische stellung kann es auch auf sein
verhältnis zur theologie und das ist
jetzt das dritte zitat was ich auch noch
kurz vorlesen möchte man erkennt aber
das ausgezeichnete der erstellung kann
es auch und gerade in seiner besonderen
stellung zum theologischen problem er
und nur er ist nämlich auch und gerade
hier der mann in welchem das jahrhundert
sich selber in seinen grenzen versteht
keiner weit und breit hat das was im 18
jahrhundert theologisch dass das 18
jahrhundert theologisch meint und wollte
so entschlossen so hart und konsequent
im gegensatz zu russo so unsentimental
klar
und im gegensatz zu lessing so unfrei
maurisch offen heraus gebracht wie er
jetzt kommt die entscheidende passage er
hat aber auch keiner
es hat aber auch keiner weit und breit
so deutlich gesehen dass dieses
theologischen meinen und wollen 12
begrenzt von einer nicht relativ sind
absolut anderen theologischen
möglichkeiten erkannt hat für seine
person keinen augenblick daran gedacht
diese grenze zu überschreiten
es steht wirklich auf beiden füßen
innerhalb dieser grenzen
aber wie ablehnend wie polemisch immer
erste tor also bei kant zeigt sich
bereits die möglichkeit einer
theologischen perspektive die jedoch wie
bad im folgenden zeigen möchte erst noch
ausgearbeitet werden muss
interessant ist das bad sich mit kants
kritik der praktischen vernunft so
befasst dass er den individuellen
menschen den wirklichen menschen hier
thematisiert sieht und dann wie ich im
vierten zitat das jetzt nicht ganz
vorlesen möchte aber nur kurz streifen
möchte zeigt dass darin gewissermaßen
existenz existenzielle vollzüge zu
finden sind
das schreibt von einer bescheidenheit
die sich darin zeige einer ganz anderen
herrlichkeit aber auch in etwas
ehrfurcht gebietenden und das sind
durchaus begriffe die jetzt selber nicht
aus der kantischen technologie entliehen
sind das sind externe kategorien die
durchaus existenz philosophischen
beiklang haben die aber gerade in dieser
grenzziehung in dieser kritischen
philosophie bei kant zu finden glaubt
also hier zeigt sich dass markant
interpretation sehr eigenständig ist wie
ich im folgenden zu zeigen versuche er
glaube ich dass das kann dass das bad
von späteren zum früheren tut aber ich
komme noch genauer drauf also dass jetzt
mehr oder weniger bekannt eben auch
seine überzeugung wiederfinden möchte
dabei nicht bleibt sondern dann in einem
entscheidenden schritt auf den ich auch
bald zu sprechen kommen werden doch auch
über kant hinaus gehen möchte kritik ist
nach bad nicht wie ich schon sagte
gleichzusetzen mit etwas destruktiven
mit einer zerstörung von werten sondern
und das ist auch interessant hat zu tun
mit etwas was einen glauben an die
vernunft zu tun hat wer die vernunft
kritisiert der beschränkt sie nicht im
schlechten sinne der stellt sie nicht
ins abseits sondern der befasst sich mit
der vernunft auf eine besonders intime
art und weise was auch wieder zu dem
vierten zitat passt wo barth gewisse
existenz philosophische termini ins
spiel bringen es hier zumal das 15 zitat
vor kritik der vernunft heißt
verständigung der vernunft über sich
selber ihr pathos ist in keiner weise
das 1
verneinung es ist vielmehr so
ausdrücklich wie nur möglich dass eine
bejagung der vernunft kannte ist nicht
jacobi kannte es nicht armen oder
claudius oder lavater kant ist kant und
seine vernunft kritik hat mit kultur
müdigkeit mit aufklärungs möglichkeit
nicht das geringste zu tun kann hat und
kann verlangt einen geradezu unbedingten
glauben an die vernunft aber die
glaubwürdige vernunft ist ihm allein die
aller erst in bezug auf sich selbst
selber vernünftig gewordene vernunft sie
auf den plan zu führen ist der sinn
seiner vernunft kritik ganz interessant
fand ich hier die wendung eines glaubens
an die vernunft eine glaubwürdige von
uns das ist jetzt natürlich kein
theologischer glauben aber es ist doch
mehr als nur eine abstrakte vernunft
kritik sondern ist eine intime beziehung
zu diesen vermögen was eben diese kritik
nach dem bad ausmacht welche rolle teilt
dann bat kant zu kant ist verbaut der
zitat vollende der mensch bist 18
jahrhunderts diese rolle besitzt kann
nach bad auch deswegen weil er gerade
das achtzehnte zum neunzehnten
jahrhundert überführt hat also in cannes
zwerg vollzieht sich diese wende der
aufklärung und bart sieht im sinne
dieser dieses glaubens der vernunft in
cannes eine ganz besondere form der
aufklärung realisiert noch mal ein zitat
das zitat nummer sechs aufklärung vor
kant war die unbedingte uferlose und
damit doch letztendlich unsichere selbst
drei young der vernunft wie man aber
auch die geistigkeit kannst und die
geistlichkeit nach kant als aufklärung
bezeichnen was man in gewissem sinne
nicht nur tun kann sondern tun muss so
ist sie jetzt jedenfalls bedingte
bestimmte erst und nur insofern sichere
sie ist kritischer selbst bejagung der
vernunft geworden das ist das neu bei
kann und das ist auch eine neue zeit der
geistlichkeit des 19 jahrhunderts
im gegensatz zu der des 18 jahrhunderts
man sieht also das bad nicht mehr hinter
kant zurückfallen möchte sondern das bad
durchaus im ausgang von kant neue wege
beschreiben möchten und zwar vor allem
wenn es um die bedeutung der religion
und aber auch der theologie nach kant
geht trotz aller positiver würdigungen
der kantischen vernunft kritik hier ist
eben dieses stichwort der glaubwürdigen
von den vorherigen zitat ist es doch so
dass bad in kans vernunft philosophie
ein problem findet und das ist vor allem
nachbarin problem des bösen zu finden
das böse ist wie bad kann interpretiert
ein notwendiger vernunft begriff und bat
bezieht sich hier auf die religion
innerhalb der grenzen der bloßen
vernunft und in diesem stück des bösen
diesem lehrstück des bösen sieht barth
in ganze philosophie an eine grenze
kommen die immer nennt selbst mit
vernünftigen mitteln nicht mehr
bewältigt werden kann kann sagt an einer
zentralen stelle der religions- schrift
dass das böse ein vernunft ursprung hat
und an diesem punkt setzt bad an um dann
am ende trotz aller positiver würdigung
doch über kant hinauszugehen tat spricht
auch mit blick auf karlsruhes
philosophie von einem problem begriff
und der problem begriff besteht darin
dass hier zitat der träger der vernunft
das heißt der mensch wie als maß aller
dinge
so auch als maß der religion und ihrer
praktischen und theoretischen
möglichkeiten und jetzt kommt es gerade
als mass gottes gedacht und vorgesehen
ist
das ist die grenze der kantischen
religionsphilosophie die eben die
vernunft am ende zum absoluten
bezugspunkt nimmt und die aber wie im
bösen bereits deutlich wird in sich
gespalten ist und die sich selbst nicht
so realisieren kann wie es kann wohl
dachte noch mein bezug auf das böse wie
schon sagte im bösen zeigt sich dass die
vernunft nach partien falls bekannt
nicht ihr eigentliches programm
realisieren kann die vernunft ist auch
der ursprung des bösen und das nennt
barth wiederum ein wieder vernünftiges
aber merkwürdigerweise gerade als
solches der ordnung des vernünftigen
doch mit angehörigen prinzip das prinzip
des radikalen lösen
jetzt ist es so dass wir grundsätzlich
mit allen denkern dieser vorgeschichte
der theologie des 19 jahrhunderts umgeht
im ausgang von kant drei wege
identifiziert wie sich die weitere
technologische entwicklung hätte
ereignen können das ganz interessant
weil hier jetzt das eigentliche anliegen
bartz in seiner theologie in seiner
geschichte des 19 jahrhunderts der
theologie dann mehr oder weniger zur
sprache kommt zum einen und das ist die
erste möglichkeit die jetzt bat im
ausland anzieht könnte man und das hat
sich auch nach bad so entwickelt nur
noch ein geschlossenes system entwickeln
wie es sich bei kant fand also dass man
bei kant alle vorliegenden lücken noch
schließt und eben mehr oder weniger noch
besser als kant wird und dieses kann
tische programm einer theologisch
entwicklung findet barth bei ritschel
aber auch bei wilhelm hermann realisiert
das ist eine erste möglichkeit wie man
jetzt mit kant in die theologie des 19
jahrhunderts übergehen kann das wäre
sozusagen ein besserer ein
ausgearbeiteter bekannt eine zweite
theologische entwicklung wäre nach bad
die einer immanenten kritik und zwar so
dass der vernunft begriff der sich im
bösen eben letztendlich spaltet und
nicht mehr im bösen diesem problem des
vernunft ursprung des bösen ein einheit
aufweisen lässt dass man hier immer
nennt mehr oder weniger auf die
notwendigkeit hin weist diese diesen
vernunft begriff systematisch zu
erweitern und zwar wie barth meint durch
das vermögen des gefühls oder auch die
ahndung und hier bringt im bad vor allem
schleiermacher im spiel als er
schleiermacher ist für bad diese zweite
möglichkeit wie man im ausgang von kant
eine theologie im 19 jahrhundert
entwickeln könnte er nennt aber auch
noch jacobi und friis wir haben das er
gestern gehört auch mit rudolf otto ich
denke dass man das durchaus auch in
diese zweite entwicklung noch nehmen
könnte aber er nennt jetzt hier
schleiermacher im sinne dieser
immanenten kritik im gegensatz zu dieser
ersten möglichkeit der bloßen
fortführung und ausgestaltung der
kantischen einem vernunft theorie und
entscheidend ist jetzt aber der schritt
im moment die dritte möglichkeit und
darauf dann geht es jetzt bald in dieser
diese passage es gibt auch eine dritte
möglichkeit
und zwar besteht die darin dass man ganz
vernunft begriff tatsächlich noch mehr
in seine grenzen weiß ich zitiere die
dritte möglichkeit würde meines
erachtens darin bestehen dass die
theologie sich der philosophie gegenüber
bescheiden würde auf ihren eigenen füßen
zu stehen dass sie ihren methodischen
ausgangspunkt ebenso bestimmt in der
offenbarung wie jene der vernunft
erkennen und also mit der philosophie
ein zwiegespräch nicht aber selber in
den mantel der philosophie sind ein
quasi philosophisches selbstgespräch
führen würde
das ist die dritte möglichkeit wo hat
jetzt doch etwas mehr und das bringt ihn
auch wieder zu seiner die elektrischen
theologie die eigenständigkeit der
theologie dann doch auch gegenüber der
philosophie betont im ausgang von kant
und diesen weg
sid jetzt bat noch zu wenig beschritten
bad gibt sich also dann letztendlich
recht entscheiden sie noch ein zitat wir
werden auch besser verzichten auf den
kühnen versuch kann besser verstehen zu
wollen als er sich selber verstanden hat
das wäre also diese erste weg der
technologischen entwicklung der dann bei
hermann endet das heißt aus der
philosophie kants eine andere religion
zügig folgen und aufbauen zu wollen als
die mit der er selbst sein werk in
theologischer hinsicht grün zu sollen
und können gemeint hat die frage ob das
nicht möglich wäre darf gestellt werden
aber selbst wenn die frage nach dem
theologischen belangen einer solchen
besseren auf kant aufgebauten
religionsphilosoph geklärt wäre so würde
es sich bei der arbeit um jedenfalls um
ein rein aber eine rein philosophische
aufgabe handeln philosophie aber ist
eine strenge und weitsichtige
wissenschaft für sich und es steht dem
theologen nicht an so zu tun als befinde
er sich in der lage gleichsam im
nebenamt auch noch eine philosophie
vortrag vorzutragen und ausgerechnet
einem kant etwas am zeug flicken zu
können also hier sieht man durchaus eine
gewisse ehrfurcht gegenüber hand und bat
ende dann mit einer recht generellen
aussage über die koexistenz von
philosophie und theologie und das ist
ganz merkwürdig wir die bezeichnung sagt
sie tat das nebeneinander von theologie
und philosophie ist ja vielleicht eine
angelegenheit über die sich ohne ironie
in der tat nicht reden lässt auch von
der theologie aus nicht das ist die
verhältnis bestimmung an ironische ein
ironisches verhältnis das verhältnis von
theorie und philosophie da muss man sich
fragen was meinte damit wohl das gemeint
dass beide oder jedenfalls die theologie
doch immer sehr auf die philosophie im
ausgang von kant geschaut hat dass sie
aber es vielleicht doch nicht so tun
sollte wie sie es tat und dass sie diese
anziehungskraft die gewissermaßen von
der philosophie ausgeht akzeptieren muss
ohne sich ihr ganz hinzugeben diese
gravitation
das wäre vielleicht mit diesem
ironischen verhältnis gemeint hat sich
mir nicht ganz erschlossen aber er sagt
ist ein ironisches verhältnis vielleicht
auch ein fragwürdiges verhältnissen es
ist als ich selbstverständlich sondern
es muss problematisiert werden aber in
dieser problematik durchaus nicht zu
ernst genommen werden
jetzt komme ich auf den nächsten punkt
ganz kurz bad und novalis direkt an
dieses kapitel über kant findet sich in
diesem werk von bad über die theologie
des 19 jahrhunderts eine kurze passage
über normales und novalis dient für bad
als inbegriff wie auch kant und hegel
für eine ganz bestimmte geisteshaltung
bad sagt zu den früheren anti dann
könnte man sagen jetzt bei novalis sagte
er
zitat die romantik war nicht die tiefste
nicht die radikalste die tiefste das war
kant die radikale zwar regelt und nicht
die reifste form der großen geistes
bewegung die die aufklärung und das 18
jahrhundert überhaupt vollendet und
überwunden und die die typische
geistigkeit des 19 jahrhunderts
begründet hat nicht die tiefste das wird
auch wohl die philosophie kants gewesen
sein
nicht die radikalste die werden wir bei
hegel kennenlernen
mit blick auf die theologie des 19
jahrhunderts kritisiert dann bat am
beispiel von novalis dass die romantik
hinter sich dass sie die mit blick auf
die theologie des 1900 kritisiert dass
die roma dass sie die romantik hinter
sich gelassen aber sie nicht los
geworden sein
sie sei irgendwie zutiefst auch
romantische theologie sofern sie durch
schleiermacher beherrscht und bestimmt
ist braucht das nicht erst begründet zu
werden
ich wende mich jetzt im nächsten punkt
bartz hegels rezeption zu die ähnlich
wie diejenige von kant recht ausführlich
ausgefallen ist
auch in hegels sieht barth einen typus
ein inbegriff einer
geistesgeschichtlichen entwicklung
verkörpern während kant wie ich schon
sagte als der holländer als eine
gestalte vollendung aufzufassen ist der
vollendung der aufklärung des 18
jahrhunderts die nicht mehr nur die
vernunft zu sehr in die schranken weist
oder vielleicht sogar alles zerstört wie
kannte ja vorgeworfen wurde der alle
szenen die ideen gottes der
unsterblichkeit der seele und so weiter
sieht eben bad in kant ein der die
vernunft versucht zu verstehen und
jemand der mit der vernunft mehr oder
weniger in ein intimes verhältnis
eintritt diese glaubend glaubhafte
glaubwürdige vernunft und so ist es
eigentlich auch ganz ähnlich bei der
analyse der hegelschen philosophie da
bezeichnet jetzt das hat sieben barth
hegels philosophie als die philosophie
des selbstvertrauens
er tat es handelt sich um philosophie
und also um das selbstvertrauen des
denkenden menschen
hegels vertrauen gilt die äquivalenz
zwischen seinem denken und dem von ihm
gedacht
das heißt der völligen gegenwart seines
denkens in dem von ihm gedachten und der
völligen gegenwart ist von ihm gedachten
in seinem denken anders jetzt als kant
verdient die grenze und die kritik eine
wichtige rolle gespielt hatte ist es bei
hegel so das macht kann sehr klar
deutlich dass diese grenzen verriegelt
so nicht mehr gelten also die
erscheinung und der begriff die das
äußere die real philosophie und die
begriffs logik die stehen in engen
verhältnis das eben nicht mehr dieses
ist wie es bei kant war
und darin liegt dann aber auch für bad
das problem bei hegel und zwar deswegen
weil hegel als der große länder und
überwindung der aufklärung jetzt endlich
ein gottesbegriff ansetzt der wie es bei
kann schon angelegt war aber nicht ganz
so extrem
doch dazu führt dass wir gottes freiheit
wie backt am ende nicht mehr fahren
können
ich habe hier wieder ein recht langes
zitat das ist die zeit nummer 8 und
darin wird nach bad die grenze oder die
problematik der hämischen philosophie
besonders deutlich lesens mal vor der
tat das problem besteht also darin dass
die identifizierung gottes bei hegel mit
der dialektischen methode auch wenn sie
nicht seine idee eine identifizierung
mit dem lebens aktes menschen bedeuten
würde
eine kaum tragbare einschränkung ja
aufhebung der souveränität gottes sagt
die die bezeichnung dessen was hegel
geist idee vernunft und so weiter nennt
als gott erst recht fragwürdig macht
dieser gott der gold eagles ist
mindestens sein eigener gefangener alles
begreifen begreift er zuletzt und zu
höchst auch sich selbst und in dem ihr
das im bewusstsein des menschen tut wird
und ist von menschen alles aus alles was
gott ist und tut als dessen eigene
notwendigkeit eingesehen
es kann nun in der offenbarung nicht nur
um eine freie tag gottes gehen sondern
gott muss so funktionieren wie wir ihnen
in der offenbarung funktionieren sehen
ja es ist ihm notwendig sich zu
offenbaren
das kindliche bewusstsein dass der
offenbarung teilhaftig ist erweist sich
damit als moment in dem begriff in dem
prozess gottes selber notwendigkeit ist
die schöpfung notwendig auch die
versöhnung wo wenn sich für gott selber
ist die gemeinde in der der geist der
gemeinde und damit erst geist und gott
sein kann wäre er nicht der geistige
so wäre er nicht gott und muss offener
geist der gemeinde ist ist er gott ich
bin notwendig verkommen das ist der
grund des hebräischen gottvertrauens der
grund weshalb ist sofort und ohne
weiteres auch als selbstvertrauen
verstanden werden kann und sich selbst
verstanden hat gegen hat indem er die
dialektische methode der logik zum wesen
gottes machte die erkenntnis der realen
dialektik der gnade die in der freiheit
gottes berührt ist unmöglich gemacht auf
dem boden dieser dialektik wäre das
unternehmen einer notwendigkeit unter
der gott selber stehen soll
zu reden in der wurzel unmöglich die
dialektik in der wir selbst existieren
eine methode die wir jederzeit selbst
hand zu haben vermögen ist jedenfalls
nicht die reale dialektik der gnade also
in diesem punkt in diesem glas erlangen
zitat wird deutlich dass bei hegel
letztendlich die aufhebung der grenzen
der vernunft die sich bei kannten noch
finden wie es zu einem gottesverständnis
führt was bestimmten theologischen
intuition oder grund überzeugen oder
vielleicht sogar auch notwendigkeiten im
wege steht und allen voran ist hier die
freiheit gottes zu nennen die fahrt
durch die logik des begriffs die
dialektische entwicklung bei hegel
eingeschränkt sieht
hier kann man sich jetzt fragen warum
bad jetzt nicht auf etwa schelling
eingegangen ist nur also schelling
betont immer wieder eben auch in der
freiheits schrift wie ja auch den titel
sagt die freiheit gottes und das hatte
mich also sehr gewundert dass sich hier
an dieser stelle wo barth mehr oder
weniger fast schon eine ähnliche kritik
wie schelling zu unternehmen scheint
hier der bezug zur schelling nicht nicht
ins spiel kommt jedenfalls nicht in
dieser geschichte der theologie des
neunzehnten jahrhunderts und so endet
auch parts analyse von hebels
philosophie recht ernüchternd bad sagt
um diese analyse zu ende zu führen
zitat so müssen wir uns damit zufrieden
geben hegel als den der war zu verstehen
eine große frage eine große enttäuschung
vielleicht doch auch eine große
verheißung also also bat sieht durchaus
dass hegels philosophie große probleme
mit sich bringt daraus eine adäquate
theologie zu entwickeln und das führt
mich auch zum schluss punkt meines
vortrags
grundsätzlich lässt sich sagen dass karl
barth durchaus wie jetzt hab versucht
habt zeigen anhand von verschiedenen
zutaten dem vernunft begriff eine
wichtige rolle zugestehen dass er
gewissermaßen seine einsichten der wort
gottes theologie der dialektischen
theologie rückblickend diesem buch diese
vorlesung waren 1933 wie mir scheint
anhand dieser großen figuren allen voran
kann aber auch regel durch noch einmal
durchführen möchte nochmal
rekonstruieren möchte diese
auseinandersetzung mit kant und hegel
ist durchaus immer nennt so das bad die
system sprengen denn im moment bei kant
ist es das böse bei hegel ist es die
notwendigkeit der dialektik also sehr
scharf erkennt diese diagnose der
kritischen grenzen beide denker dann
dazu wiederum nutzt um mit blick auf die
weitere technologische entwicklung
erklärungsmuster zu gewinnen die in
ihnen die lage versetzen auch andere
entwicklungsmöglichkeiten als diejenige
die sich tatsächlich vollzogen haben zu
denken und mir scheint dass er damit
nicht zuletzt auch an seine eigene
theologie denkt die er als eine
alternative zu bestehenden theologisch
entwicklung vor allem im ende des 19
jahrhunderts auch in stellung zu bringen
sucht
kannte ist also könnte man sagen und
hegel auch für bad am ende doch auch ein
instrument mit dem er seine eigene
theologische überzeugung rechtfertigen
möchte und das scheint mir ein ziemlich
geschickter zug zu sein sodass ich
nämlich bad jetzt im nachhinein von 1933
oder eben auch 1946 dann umso besser
auch gegen den vorwurf verteidigen kann
orthodox zu sein an schlechten sinn oder
vernunft unkritisch zu sein nein er kann
es zeigen dass durch die analyse der
vernunft kritik bei kant durch die
analyse des absoluten idealismus bei
hegel kritikpunkte finden die seine
eigene theologie motivieren und das
scheint mir letztendlich das anliegen
gewesen zu sein
das wort hier sich vorgenommen hat wie
er es in seiner geschichte theologie des
19 jahrhunderts entwickelt hat